les âmes ne va pas déflorer tout le film
et je vous propose de regarder un petit
extrait de ce film donc dans lequel vous
apparaissez avec thierry lhermitte et
coluche je te présente micky c'est
quelqu'un qui compte énormément dans ma
vie salut
tu pourrais m'expliquiez ce que tu
fabriques danse plumard je me suis fais
draguer et ça t'arrive souvent oui
quand les mecs son genre ouais eh ben
dis donc tu dois en connaître un rayon
sur le matelasserie française
il s ne sont pas tous copains je suis
par son copain je suis son ami lui même
son meilleur ami
nuance il prend aucune décision
importante sont consultés j'ai une
énorme influence sur lui ça fait dix ans
que c'est comme ça et personne n'a
réussi à nous éloigner un lot et mitsou
même une femme et des femmes il y en a
elles pensent elles arrivent et
repartent et nous reste on bouge pas et
on les regarde s'éloigner